bienvenue à rdi le réseau de la
formation c'est ici qu'arrivent soit par
câble par satellite ou encore parler
téléphonique
toutes les sources d'information qui
viennent de l'extérieur de montréal vers
9h ce matin est survenue une violente
explosion dans un édifice fédéral de la
ville d'oklahoma city comme on le voit
sur ces images l'explosion a été
tellement forte qu'elle a été ressenti à
30 milles à la ronde
le verdict est tombé pour promenades au
coupable coupable de meurtre prémédité
d'agression sexuelle grave d'enlèvement
de séquestration et d'outragé à un
cadavre à bernardo n'est pas sorti du
bois avant au moins 25 à sarajevo reste
ville unie avec un parlement élu un
président bosniaque d'abord serbe
ensuite en alternance il faudra une
conférence de la paix dans les
prochaines semaines l'attentât s'est
produit alors que le chef du
gouvernement regagne sa voiture
soudain un jeune homme est sorti de la
foule et a tiré trois balles en gars qui
ont dit ça kraby les bâtons de dynamite
placé dans le véhicule était soit
téléguidé soit fixée au démarrage jamais
on n'avait vu à montréal ni innocent
être la victime de ce genre d'attentât
monsieur de la commission
bien de prendre d'avancé si la tendance
se maintient l'option du non remportera
ce référendum je le regrette de vous
annoncer que les propriétaires se sont
finalement résignés pour transpirer le à
denver au colorado la fère s'est conclu
la nuit dernière
roy a été échangé à l'avalanche du
colorado
quand allait s'adresser au président